how much for jobless do we have a hot
minute in 24 seconds which is well let's
just say like 15 of those seconds are
like made on Unreal Engine name of game
ps4 sweet logos a lot of logos so this
video I'm gonna have to get creative the
latest hot Hollywood movie franchise to
get the video game treatment is Forrest
Gump no but I wish it was ice Planet of
the Apes
so panic makes the final frontier it's
actually the last frenzy I really just
want it to be put the fight a party last
party is coming out later this year what
they've done is they've removed all of
the interaction like there's no
navigation and it's basically just
distilled down to dialogue choices
mm-hmm it's an interactive movie in the
video game space it's not Futurama basic
yes you'd like to see Calculon do his
taxes first um the watery cool about it
is it's play link enabled so it's really
nice the the guy who was from The
Imaginarium who we were chatting to
about the game he was saying that
basically like they got the idea because
he would playing games like heavy rain
heavy rain will come up a lot yes they
really like heavy rain so here if I have
you rainin like his wife would come and
sit down next to him and she could like
appreciate the story as much as he could
because they get to dialogue choices so
with Planet of the Apes it's the same
kind of deal but you can link it to your
mobile phone it's kind of yeah it
becomes like a communal party game
experience almost it does so if there's
a diode choice that needs to be made you
can hit whichever one that you want to
go for but you could also hit the one
that you want to go for it we both
choose different dialogue options then
the person who basically buzzes in the
fastest you have like an override and
everybody gets one yeah and you don't
get that override back until everyone
else is used there's it's quite an
interesting way of getting around that
and it does mean that it's quite like
you don't have to sit and discuss
options of people you can if you were to
stalemate and no one uses their override
because you can change your mind but
it's quite a nice way of kind of
keeping that pace and that kind of yeah
and letting you kind of energy going
yeah it helps direct the story a little
bit and also introduces a bit of drama
when someone does something unexpected
like abusing Apes yeah so you played the
story from both sides so there's
obviously a human faction they are like
farmers they're Hardy people because
they've managed to survive like 15
audios after the breakout the simian flu
you know some plays Apes who if you
remember the movies Cober the ape who
rebels with good reason I mean they were
under koba's leadership but then kind of
got out of Dodge before things really
hit the fan so it's interesting because
there's a lot of different end games you
can have yeah so you can hide it's very
like until don't have your reign in that
regard is that you know you can eat can
win humans can win you can find peace
all those different various options
where like various people will die yeah
but the thing that got me is you could
technically rig it if you were going
yeah if you yeah you could try and force
the decision so that one side is clearly
winning over the other side but we did
ask them about this yeah because this
was my sort of main concern I would say
going in when he was saying that like
the writers were the first people to
come on board which in game development
is very common not common at all
so it's interesting and he also said
that yeah sure you could make a decision
and be you know I Pro Apes the whole way
but you don't know how the NPC's and the
other characters in the game are going
to react mmm no they could end up
completely undermining you or they could
just like not agree with what you're
doing so they have to create enough of a
kind of like gray area yeah and like a
lot of these games they have this kind
of not problem but they've operate in a
way that the paths always branch out at
the start and middle fight always funnel
backs and funnels back into one or two
endings so I'm interested in seeing
given the factions that are oh I play
and you know other people will kind of
influencing the decisions that are made
how that kind of that final part of it
kind of shakes out I hope that because
there is a lot the world is actually you
know there's the apes are kind of like
they they've kind of ostracized them
themselves from the rest of the ape
community so they're kind of
from all the stuff that's happening
between Caesar and witzy but like I'm
interested there's a lot of like
storytelling potential because they're
trying to you know they're trying to
make it on their own and they have this
small community and it's a family as
well yeah are you saying that they
behave sort of like the Godfather
everyone yeah kind of like follows along
so there's like really interesting
opportunity for drama and good
storytelling within those characters and
also with the humans
you know the humans like always
portrayed or very often portrayed as as
bad as the enemy funny but the the one
human scene that we got to play through
they were literally tortured by ryan at
the same time there were a few people
amongst that group who were doing the
torturing that were kind of like wincing
and kind of so lucky
yeah I said us and in the game so like
you very quickly have I in the brief
time we were with the game you could see
the nuances and what it was trying to go
for it wants to create this kind of like
great like you said gray area where some
of the Apes about something it's a goods
and you is interested in seeing how they
work that into like a decision-making
process and you know some of those
characters are gonna die which is gonna
be sad but I'm looking forward to kind
of like getting attached to those
characters again and seeing how it all
shakes out it's an interesting
interesting game they talk a lot about
heavy rain and so they've actually got
the cinematic director from heavy rain I
think is the director on this now
obviously because it's Andy Serkis is
Imaginarium the whole emphasis of a
motion capture yeah which is super cool
and they gave some really interesting
statistics like one day in the motion
capture studio would create enough
animations that 400 animators would have
to make if they were manually so like
the point was like that one of the
although it's a game for everyone to
enjoy one of the things that they were
doing was experimenting with this new
technology and a new way of developing
games and that is kind of using mocap as
the driving force behind all the visual
stuff and they said you know like the
production schedule is much shorter than
traditional games here
and like that allows them to create
games quicker this isn't an episodic
series one thing you're not gonna be you
know like $60 fifty pounds it will they
haven't confirmed my point just yet but
it will be cheaper yeah it'll be two
three hours long you can play up to four
people in one go and it just kind of
sounds like arenas thing that you can
sit on the counter together and like
blast through I'm sitting yeah I think
price right and kind of like it seems
like the kind of thing that you do like
instead of just watch a movie let's do
this thing
so if it works it could be a really
interesting kind of change in the type
of games that we get all the experiences
we get because like people always say oh
this is just an interactive movie and
they use it as like almost in a
derogatory way or I shouldn't recommend
me but like the idea of an interactive
movie is quite appealing right you get
to see well written well acted you know
stories and you also get to have your
own input on how those stories may out
so personally I'm excited I'm I hope it
works out because it means that they can
spread out and you know they've got the
Imaginarium behind them and we've all
seen what they're capable of creating in
like all the various films that I work
with so it starts with eggs but it could
become unique you know original stories
could be other properties other
franchises like that's an interesting
step for video games the thing is
whether saying all that is it is really
cool but they were saying that they were
doing this like enabling play link and
multiple people to play this story was
to get out of the audience out of the
video game audience they wanted to make
it more mainstream but the fact that you
are locked to owning a Playstation or
device or a PC kind of you know there
needs to be another thing that it comes
out on I think to be able to really open
this up to other people you know I mean
Sony enabled TVs so many little TVs you
know I mean something like that you need
to kind of have that extra accessibility
yeah and it's an interesting it's a
tricky proposition as well for them
because they it's it's a not a rich but
it's something new that effectively they
need the hardcore to evangelize it to
the to the casuals to make that happen
and obviously we're not gonna get into a
debate about what is a game and what is
not okay
but like the hardcore community at least
you know online the volkl people they
see something like that where their
interactions are quite limiting and they
kind of put off by that they've a lot of
us have warmed to it now with stuff like
Telltale's games and life is strange and
a lot of like adventure story and that
kind of stuff so I don't think it's a
massive problem but it is a kind of risk
that they're taking like where they're
hoping that the hardcore gamers will
understand be in a kind of idea behind
it and what they're trying to do and
then solve that to their friends and you
know it's interesting it works I mean it
could be interesting if they do you know
what telltale does it conventions and
stuff where they have like a group play
you know make twitchplayspokemon or
something you have like a massive amount
of people coming together it's basically
the future Armas get me to quiet yeah
you have pressed - I didn't I'm almost
positive you did I think it could be
very very interesting to see where who
knows like yes from now that could be
the way you go to a cinema and
experience a movie that could be an
option like massive screen all of you
get your phones out phones in a cinema
anyway for more I'm Planet of the Apes
make sure you keep your eyes peeled to
games for calm I need you back on this
game